merci la parole et à monsieur yannick
moreau merci monsieur le président en
cette période de vendée globe ma
question s'adresse au premier ministre
d'un gouvernement à la dérive
il ne vous reste plus que cinq mois pour
sauver ce mandat catastrophiques
redresser la barre faire baisser le
chômage et permettre ainsi à votre ami
françois hollande de se représenter cinq
mois c'est long c'est même interminable
avec les socialistes au pouvoir
les années comptent double cinq mois
assez long pour tous les français qui
souffrent du juge
[Applaudissements]
je jeu reprend et ça fonctionne
oui bon
comment
en cette période de vendée globe
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre d'un gouvernement à la dérive
il ne vous reste plus que cinq mois pour
sauver ce mandat catastrophiques
redresser la barre faire baisser le
chômage et permettre ainsi à votre ami
françois hollande de se représenter cinq
mois c'est long c'est même interminable
avec les socialistes au pouvoir
les années comptent double cinq mois
c'est long pour tous les français qui
souffrent du chômage
je te veux être jugé sur les résultats
eh bien nous y sommes avec 1 million 600
mille de demandeurs d'emplois
supplémentaires
votre bilan est nul vous êtes
disqualifié cinq mois c'est ton pour
tous les entrepreneurs de notre pays aux
prises avec le rsi les travailleurs
détachés et un code du travail de trois
mille quatre cents pages cinq mois cet
interminable on en vient même à se
demander si les socialistes n'ont pas
inventé la machine à arrêter le temps
cinq mois cet interminable pour les
millions de français espérant une as une
alternance radical puissante qui
remettent la france sur les rails de la
liberté d'entreprendre de la croissance
et de l'emploi
cinq mois cet interminable pour les
millions de français qui espère un
allongement des charges un allègement
des normes des règles des impôts qui
brille nos entreprises la france dispose
d'énergie et d'atouts considérables qui
ne demande qu'à s'exprimer
pour peu qu'on ose enfin faire confiance
aux entrepreneurs et leur la paix
de la lisibilité de la stabilité de la
confiance et de la souplesse
voilà l'alternance forte que nous
proposons alors ma question est simple
monsieur le premier ministre
à cinq mois de la fin de votre mandat
que comptez vous faire pour rendre vos
derniers jours utile à la croissance à
l'emploi et à tous ceux qui envers et
contre tous ont l'audace d'investir dans
notre pays
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
s'il vous plaît monsieur le député
moreau j'ai eu l'occasion d'entendre
deux fois votre votre question donc
j'avais bien compris le sens de votre
interpellation il reste en effet cinq
mois pour tirer d'abord et moi je le
respecte les conséquences de l'exercice
démocratique auquel vous êtes en train
de vous livrer cinq mois pour pouvoir
faire les comparaisons entre ce que nous
avons engagé
est ce que vous proposez cinq mois pour
dire aux français que vous voulez mettre
en cause et le modèle républicain et le
modèle social français par les
propositions qui sont les vôtres et que
vous allez assumer parfaitement aussi
bien sur l'idée que vous vous faites de
l'état des services publics de l'école
et là moi je souhaite mais le débat j'ai
vu est engagée parmi vous vous nous
disiez comment vous allez faire en
supprimant 500 mille postes de
fonctionnaires et d'agents pour protéger
les français
éduquer nos enfants et protéger notre
modèle social
cinq mois pour tout simplement avoir une
idée de ce qu'elle société sur tous les
sujets qui ont été encore abordé
aujourd'hui c'est à dire refuser
d'engager le pays dans ce qui est une
vraie révolution conservatrice cinq mois
pour ce qui concerne le chef du
gouvernement de poursuivre le travail au
service des français
cinq mois pour la gauche pour redonner
de l'espérance bâtir un projet qui soit
adaptée aux réalités du monde de
l'europe et de la france cinq mois pour
avec de l'espoir de la fierté et de la
confiance
refuser votre projet compath l'extrême
droite qui oui peut être aux portes du
pouvoir et permettre à ce pays de
continuer de la france fière de ses
valeurs
en tout cas pour ce qui concerne
monsieur le député puisque vous m'en
donner la possibilité
j'assumerai toutes mes responsabilités
parce que moi je crois dans ce pays
je crois dans ce que nous avons engagé
je crois dans l'incarnation des
institutions neige - dans la démocratie
et je veux que les français pas
uniquement ceux gauche soient fiers
et confiance en eux mêmes et refuse un
projet qui les ferait revenir en arrière
merci monsieur